the topic tonight
is can
you turn a hoe into a housewife
but in order to answer this question i
think we got to define what is a hoe
so i want to hear from the guys
what do you guys think a hoe is
going chris
to me
[Music]
what i will call her is
a girl that's
been run through
that you know about like if you don't
know she if you don't know she hasn't
been running through then like you can't
really you don't know but once you know
and it's out there like
she just has that name like you know
that you have a chance
what is what is ran through to you like
is there is it a number or is it like
yeah but
if you know somebody that smashed or you
know a couple people that smashed okay
okay that's a hell and obviously like a
number if it's
like relative to age isn't it but if
we're talking like
near the hundreds
oh hundreds yeah like oh gosh do you
know do you know girls that are near the
hundreds
i do i'm like i don't know anyone that's
slept with that many people
well that's a girl anyway you shouldn't
be near that but if you're near this
then
so so if you know like one friend that
slept with her
she's a hoe
it depends on the friend okay there's
certain people you're like yo like he
smashed
okay
so like if you don't rate him
yeah if you don't really so if you don't
rate him and he's been there you're like
you have to be hurt
like if he's ugly or something or what
what do you mean like if the guy is ugly
or like his value yeah like i think i
mean it's more of a guy thing that we
just know like
if you smash them
oh okay not like you first thing i'm
just saying like in general like if you
know that someone like you smashed then
okay
is that is that not more of a
is that not more of a reflection of your
male friends though what what you think
of your male friends as opposed to the
girl if you're kind of saying if you've
smashed him like
do you know what i mean
is that is that norm not more of a
reflection of what you think of the guy
than the girl
yeah but there's also like there's
levels in it like
there's less levels too and
you can say reflection of this person
and that person but end of the day and
if you're her
you just know from both sides that
you're a hurt
in the fine words of cardi b a hoe never
gets cold
this is my like thing to say there's
like a whole study that was released
about this recently which was but hoes
don't get
so like geordie girls up north in
newcastle renowned for going out in kind
of minus degree weather in the shortest
skirts at the highest hills yeah coats
but somehow they're absolutely fine
don't get cold every southerner will be
like
oh right
and so
someone did a whole study about cardi b
in this song saying that hoes never get
cold you know they can always wear like
minimal clothing right and they don't
get cold they're fine they're doing
their thing
um someone did a whole like masters or
phd thesis on it or whatever oh okay but
yeah so so kit what is your definition
about how
oh do you call women house you kind of
strike me as a guy that wouldn't
i don't call women highs horace
okay you know like people are
promiscuous okay i use the uh what
jordan peterson would say
um
but by definition of you know the slang
of what we would call a quote unquote i
think if a girl
if a girl
has
quote unquote gotten around i think
she's going around like a friendship
group then to that group she's going to
be seen as that she's going to be seen
as that do you know what i mean because
it's one thing to
it's one thing to get around but then
if everybody knows and you're still just
acting that way
then
you don't
if you then you're not fussed about your
reputation in that sense because you
because the reality is you know that
it's going to play a part
do you know what i mean yeah so
if you know that your reputation
if you don't care about your reputation
then you're just going to do you which
is fine each to their own
but then people are going to call you
what it is do not mean that's true yeah
yeah i kind of i kind of feel like it
depends on the motive
um behind it so
like they could be subject a and b
one could have slept with 20 and uh the
second person i slept with 20 as well
but the way the first person must have
done it like
she could have just been gassed up by
her friends and said you know what let
me just go on mad one tonight and just
just run through 10 people at once or
sorry
right or the second person
like
they fell for one put like
they weren't too smart in relation so
they liked one guy and then thought he
was going to treat him nice got [ __ ]
over yeah it's another guy got [ __ ]
over but the thing is her mercy behind
it wasn't to be a whole like to run
around you you didn't just happen sort
of thing so i feel like it depends on
the motive
interesting
okay so
for the women
yeah
do you do you think does sexual past
matter to you in a guy the sexual past
so oh like would it
like if a guy had slept with a hundred
girls before he met you do you care
no
couldn't can i swear on this by the way
yeah you could switch oh great can give
a [ __ ] yeah literally couldn't care less
yeah i don't it's not a thing for me i
don't care especially i think if we're
talking numbers i feel like people
view sexual past
really quantitatively
so really in terms of numbers and things
i don't think that's a reflection at all
of what kind of a partner you are
sexually or otherwise
i've slept with people who have slept
with loads of people who are [ __ ] and
bad i've slept with people who've slept
with minimal people and it worked well
in bed we were great whatever we had a
good relationship
so i think in terms of the quality of
the relationship you have with them
whether it's a fleeting relationship or
a lasting one i like
yeah it doesn't matter for me it's more
about how someone treats people yeah
to me there's a number where it's kind
of okay
i was having this conversation if you
slept with anyone in my family cooked
any of my sisters
i feel like that's weird close close
friends cooked
close like immediate front cooked
so just anyone that you know no but i
don't here's the thing i don't have that
many friends
there's like three people you cannot
sleep with
it's not that long
um
please don't [ __ ] my mom
um but i don't know like i guess if it's
extreme like if i did i you can't say
you say corn instead of okay
but if i got a corn cooked like that so
like to the extreme but for the most
part like i don't really care but it's
interesting so i'm going to ask the guys
the same question
sexual past with a girl does it matter
to you
yeah you start
so sexual past in sense of if we're in
london
and all right because we're in eastern i
use islam and
there's eight guys i know in east london
i've been with
it's game over like
yeah so that sort of passed but if if i
never knew what it did in the past and
you just came and no one knows you
i couldn't really care less
okay
yeah you want to feel like you you found
her yeah you don't want to
have a goal that you know everyone has
had because then like the value of it
goes away like you don't want to treat
her the same because you know like you
put in the effort
and she
she like she gave up easy for the next
man then it's like well you're a
[ __ ] like you're spending this
amount of money this amount of time yeah
and you could have done less and got the
same thing yeah so
yeah
and that's the interesting thing like i
think guys care a lot more about that
than girls
um
like i don't think girls really care at
all for the most part
but i wonder if if part of that is
because you know you're saying about
i want to feel like i found her i want
to feel like
ah
i just
i wonder if part of that is is
is to do with how we
view women within relationships and that
you
you want to feel like someone's yours or
like they've not if they've not been
with other people you feel like oh that
i think so sometimes as well i think it
can be a thing of
i think guys feel threatened by it
sometimes of like uh you've slept with
multiple other people you could sleep
with more people after me yeah it's like
but in a relationship i choose you
but the thing is like men are
biologically predispositioned to be like
different than us
so like we have biological roots and
like historically men had to ensure
paternity
so like when a girls had more partners
that would make it harder for them to
ensure that that's their kid
and so that's like why biologically like
they're different than women because for
us like if if he'd slept with someone
else like that's a sign of pre-selection
which like like if a girl do you guys
know anyone with a check mark
yeah like a blue check mark do they get
hoes
yeah like he doesn't indulge but yeah he
gets girls throwing it yeah but he's a
very good looking guy as well but yeah
but like he's checked but that's like
another sign of social status yeah of
course so it's like different for men
and women do you think does that like
bother you as a girl like do you care
about that i don't know well if
that like because a lot of girls get mad
when i talk to them like that men like
look at it one way and like women look
at another
um i mean i think it i think i think i
think it also depends what
who who you're surrounded by
i think if you're in social circles
where you all
are of the same belief that it doesn't
really matter across the board
um
then that's one thing i think
i think people are entitled to their
opinions okay i would never say to
someone you have to think and act
exactly like me right right
but i would raise the point that i feel
like sometimes people form opinions
based on prejudice okay or based on past
experiences i think that shapes
everyone's belief systems what do you
what do you mean by prejudice
so i think for some people so i'm i'm i
i'm i'm going to put this one out here
okay
okay i'm an art and feminist i believe
in equality and i believe in total
equality and that's not me saying that's
not me saying i think that there are no
biological differences between men and
women i'm not an idiot
i completely agree with that especially
we and we talked about this
there are strong physical differences
right between men and women men in
general stronger do you so then do you
pay for the dates like do you 50 50 on
dates yeah oh always for the most part
if someone look i think it's a really
nice thing if someone offers to pay for
you on a date
but i think that regardless i'm also bi
i like women and men okay so i think
that regardless of whether
um
i think that regardless of gender i
think it's a really nice thing to in the
same way like if someone holds the door
for me like thank you that is a nice
thing to do it's a nice thing to offer
to pay for someone
but
especially within the sphere of of
yeah of dating i think
i think i think i think why not i think
if someone offers and you're like no no
let's split and they're like no i insist
okay fine i don't know i've just found
that like a lot of girls i talk to like
they want equality but it's like only
when it benefits them
so like they want like because i don't
think body count is really that big of a
deal like in the term like
if that's the only double standard that
like is negative towards us like i don't
think that's that bad
but i i would say that's absolutely not
the the only doubles within within the
whole world that's definitely not the
only double standard i think it's a big
one that we can point out because i
think historically women are always
slut-shamed yeah i think even the thing
of calling someone a hoe or a [ __ ] like
especially [ __ ] that's such a harsh
word
um and i think it's conflating someone
who
has multiple sexual partners with
someone who sells their body for a
living but equally and i'm sure we're
going to talk about this afterwards yeah
i equally i'm like cool great on your
coin yeah again like i don't care if you
want to be someone who does sell sex or
is a sex worker i'm like okay but i
think in general like i think
i i think the body count isn't isn't the
only thing but it's a big one that we
can point to and i think that i
understand your reasoning about
biologically you know
men men can father way more children
than women can right right mother kids
but
we're way past that point now we are way
past the point of just
intellectually and i think that
it's just interesting because if body
count didn't actually matter like why
wouldn't everyone just say theirs
you know what i mean like usually like
people lie one way or the other do you
think well men and men inflate i think
men inflate it like women say it's lower
yeah and like usually like if i ask
people and so like would you want to
tell your body count on live
i i would love to
i can give you an estimate wait really
give you an estimate if you don't if
estimate because i
yeah because i i don't know i don't know
because i don't keep a checklist of
everyone that i've slept with because i
think that would be a little bit yeah
strange like oh so you wouldn't care
like you would say it on the live and
like you wouldn't even care yeah like it
because i think as well i think it's
important to break down social stigma
for things like that okay in the same
way i think if if guys you know if guys
feel a pressure to big up the number of
people they've slept with because they
feel like that makes them cooler and
women feel like they need to tell a
lower number because that makes them
seem more attractive you don't think
shame exists for a reason because i feel
like shame is something internal like no
one can make you feel shame
oh i think people can make you feel safe
i don't think so oh i think i think we
internalize it but i think it's stuff
that we learn like i use the example of
i used to pray the gay away when i was a
kid cause i was raised race catholic
bad catholic now
oh yeah yeah did i have uniforms yeah i
didn't go to a catholic school yeah but
but
normal schools have oh yeah yeah that's
why i i
have a question do you think do you
think that calling a girl like a hoe
is the same thing as calling a guy broke
[Music]
because like
because corner girl a hoe is like
supposed to see you're saying that to
make her less desirable to guys right
yeah so calling the guy broke is you're
saying he's not desirable to women
because women don't want guys who are
broke you're surprised
but at the same time you know
realistically like
someone
a guy can be broke and it may not matter
yeah like is it the same thing no no but
it's different though because like
if if he was ashamed to be broke
especially like in public a girl would
be like hmm
this they still wouldn't feel the same
way if they did if that makes sense if
they knew he was broke do you think so
maybe behind closed doors so if it was
like oh they just met the guy they don't
know it was broke they could already
care less than yeah but then
if in public you just got cussed out and
you're like yeah you're broke other
girls were like
yeah i'm saying yeah that like he would
he would look less desirable to them
yeah but then if it was the other way
around where they were calling a girl a
whole like oh yo
guys be like yeah and
what i'll say is that
if guys believe that
they may still have sex with her but
they wouldn't wife her up though yeah
you're saying that do you see my point i
got a question what you're saying so
um if a guy if a guy is broke yeah
he can become unbroken by getting money
yep so you can let for example win the
lottery get a good job you know just he
can he can turn that around yes you can
but how can a woman turn around being a
hoe because they've
[Music]
who said oh they stopped dating guys
around the area they stopped
guys around the area like say they're
from south
they they are guys from like north or
east or west because they're too big in
the area and it works for them
i think
but then is is i would argue that it's
ho not a mentality like i would say as a
poster you can never you want you know
that argument of once you're broke and
and i would like to also say that i i
think that this i think it's a bit of an
americanism anyway this thing like he
broke or whatever like whatever you're
gonna call it i think like in england at
least i think i think some of that
bleeds in from popular culture right
there's that song by tlc no scrubs right
i think for me i'm like it's a tune
right
[Music]
well i think
but i think like i think i think
again in the same way that you can you
can earn money
um and i would yeah i'd like to say that
someone having no money has never
stopped me from dating them i i'm
working class i wasn't raised with it
right
in my mouth but i would say in the same
way that this kind of if we're talking
about poems like i've had whole phases
or whatever
i think it's more i think i think it's
less about how many people you've slept
with than maybe your mentality the
people that you're sleeping with so i
would say if you view being a hoe
exclusively in terms of numbers then
sure like i can't magically unsleep with
people yeah i hear that but what do you
guys think like as as guys like do you
think it's more of a mentality or is it
just like a number
like when you're vetting a girl to like
date her i think i i think it's a
mentality because thing is it's like
the reason the reason i don't think it
don't think it's a number is because i'd
rather like a girl has slept with 20
guys that i don't know than two of my
friends oh yeah we talked about those do
you know what i mean yeah so because i
think especially for guys
and it varies from guy to guy but i
think especially if he's taking a girl
seriously like no guy wants to have
another man at his wedding who's been
inside his wife
they don't
so like part of it is like part of it is
part of it is like a respect thing among
your peers for men so equally
you know a lot of women
and i hear what you're saying about the
americanism right but i think the
difference is
in american culture they're just a lot
more direct whereas in british culture
here we're very
that the underlying thing is the
intention is still there
but we just don't openly say it so like
for example you know if one of your
girlfriends meets a new guy the first
thing they ask is what does he do yeah
yeah that's very true what does that
have anything to do with other than how
well can he provide
it's the exact same thing otherwise you
know it's like if you didn't do anything
or they want to see like show me a
picture that's the other thing uh girls
will either say what does he do or let
me see
show me a picture yeah whereas guys
your boy just met a new girl they're
like yo what'd she look like
um so i think i think it i think it is
mindset because
a girl can
have 20 guys but i think it's like no
one knows no one knows but i also think
you're a production of your habits
and i think that's like
you can't
undo like the habits you've created the
past like like
what you can change your habits i think
you can but i think it's hard it could
be hard but and i don't think most
people do
i think most girls that i know that like
slept around have a hard time
not doing it anymore
no i i disagree because i think a lot of
them i think a lot of them get
a lot of them get burned mm-hmm um
actually the numbers the numbers don't
support you actually what would you mean
because they surveyed women that had
like slept with more people right yeah
and they surveyed them and how much they
regretted sleeping with those like the
person right and the lower the number
was the more they regretted it but also
the more likely they were like the more
people they slept with the more likely
they were to do it again and the more
regret they felt they still would do it
again
so basically we're saying is the more
people that she slept with the more
likely she is to sleep with more people
like yeah yeah yeah
which yeah that's like
we call it hoe tendencies
but i also
would say that part of that is because i
think women who
date more frequently will have more
frequent partners or have slept with
more people
are less willing to settle yeah i think
that's another thing but what do you
define as settling because
i don't i don't just mean settling down
as in finding going steady with someone
okay and getting married because i think
i totally respect that i'm like
if that works for you some people really
really love
to have the comfort of a really
of a long-term relationship who doesn't
it offers you security emotionally if
you're married financially right think
of those sweet tax breaks
right but i mean in terms of some people
i think they
are so desperate
to
be in a relationship
and and
and so they they settle down or they get
into a relationship with someone who
they already know isn't right for them
or someone where they go yeah you know
he he treats me to a base level of okay
so i go all right yeah you know he he
gives me attention he gives me love i'll
go for him how is it how is it
because i always wonder cause people
always say like settling but isn't
like settling what you can get
it's not really settling if that's the
best you can get and i think every girl
is gonna take the best guy that you can
get to commit to her
but i think just like guys i think are
going to get the hottest nice like
hottest slash you know wifey quality
girl that they can get to yeah but i
think part of the problem is or maybe
problem is the wrong word i think part
of the thing is that people settle down
too early
before they've actually found that
person who is the best they can get they
find someone who's best in that very
moment but not the person they don't go
okay who's someone who's going to be
good for me
for a long time and i think that's when
people get trapped in relationships
which then they can't grow in and they
become toxic or they're not fun
so i would rather have more partners and
find someone where i go okay i so so in
my kind of dating life it tends to be
that i'll date someone for a few months
and i have a period of dating them more
casually and then you kind of pass
through levels right
in terms of you know do you pass these
things okay we we we go up we don't just
start like okay you've met my parents
after the first date right um and it's
so if you pass these things and i go
okay more and more i'm thinking we're
people who are more and more compatible
and i think that takes time to work that
out mm-hmm so and i think if it gets to
a point where you go actually i don't
think we are i don't then go
okay well i'm gonna stick with it anyway
because i've given you six months i go
okay actually no fine yeah but the the
issue with that is like the more women
or the more men that a woman has slept
with like her chance of a happy marriage
goes down like drastically so if a girl
is a virgin she has an 80 chance of
having a happy marriage
and it goes down to like 20 30 if she
slept with more than five people
really yeah and it's like the same it's
like
marital happiness it's like
um satisfaction with her partner because
like think about it the more people
you've experienced the more you have it
to compare to it it's the same thing men
it's similar like if a man's a virgin
like that's the highest like happiness
rate in marriage for him too but like
men it doesn't drop like i think a guy
that slept with like three girls is less
happy than a guy that's slept with eight
i don't know like it's not as drastic
like it is for women
and i also feel like it's a sort of
thing to do with sensitivity so like
your first date wouldn't be the same as
like your 30th day because like your
first date felt a bit more special but i
just keep getting more people and
getting around more people you become
less sensitive to like like
um the things that come with dating and
stuff so it will just look like a normal
thing anymore so you won't you will it
will be harder for you to just settle
and be like all right cool i think i
found a person could be like i think i
can actually do better than this
and they just keep on
i think it's like and i'm just going
from um
like women that i've coached and one or
two female friends i think a very common
thing with some women is that what will
happen is
they'll date a guy he'll have one great
quality so imagine he is like super
intelligent right and then things don't
work out she's like okay
well now i want to find a guy who's
super intelligent
and then tall she then finds that guy
it's like okay he's intelligent he's
tall
but now i want to find let's say that
doesn't work out right then she comes
across the next guy okay let's say he's
intelligent
he's got good finances but he's not tall
then he's okay i want to find a guy
who's intelligent good finances tour and
it's like
you almost the great things from the
previous partner you want that in
addition to the next partner and that's
like a trap because then what ends up
happening is you you have this long list
that ends up trying to be the perfect
person you're looking for and that just
doesn't exist and i think with guys like
it definitely happens with guys i think
from like a sexual standpoint but i
don't i don't think that's a bad thing i
don't think that's a bad thing to go i
had this relationship and i grew from it
and i went actually i don't want that in
the next relationship i go actually i
see that behavioral pattern and i can
identify and go i don't want that in the
next relationship i don't think that's a
bad thing at all well i think it's it's
more supply and demand
and i think it's just like
because
basically if you look at dating app data
it's like
80 of women are swiping on less than 20
of the guys
so this like not settling like leaves us
as like so like rotation type girl like
because you're with
you're going after a guy that is effing
with multiple girls
because like most guys if they're given
the option are gonna share the same
endeavor
yeah yeah they're sharing the same guy
yeah and so it's like then
the more the more and more we like don't
settle like the more and more a smaller
percentage of men are sleeping with all
the girls and like i don't think that
leads to like long-term happiness
being a side a side [ __ ] like is but is
that not also also the case in natural
selection anyway like if we talk about
how men are able to father more children
that happens in the natural environment
i would say for sure like
dating apps are a cesspit right right
they're not exactly the most natural
environment but i would say that happens
naturally anyway and i think that
happens even if if you if you have a
group of guys together okay you can
easily point out for the most part like
objective attractiveness of course i'm
that's not accounting for that love is
blind and sometimes people go for people
and you're like really i'm not attracted
to them at all people like different
rights right like if you find them
attractive someone else does too like
yeah yeah i got you yeah yeah so it's i
i think that's i think that's a normal
thing that
for sure like we were talking about
abundance before and the top the most
attractive guys getting the most girls
that happens in real life and on dating
apps i think maybe it's amplified more
because it is so kind of yes or no yes
or no and it takes out the whole getting
to know someone thing like but yeah i
would say if well i think i think it
happens like naturally but i just think
it's getting to the point where it's
like a little bit extreme
because you hear girls will say like six
inches six figures
what is it six inches six figures
six pack yeah
and like how many
and like like for example like a guy
you're not a guy
and even like even me right so i'm i'm
tall right so i'm six foot and if if
girls want a guy that's above six foot
that's 15
of men so that's a very like again it's
a small percentage then you add in
money you add in like other layers
but we had we had this conversation
didn't we because i was like the amount
of girls i know who on a surface level i
kind of kind of say six foot and over
and then as soon as they're off a dating
up and they meet someone in a bar and
they're like five foot seven no he's the
love of my life that's true that's true
that's true on people on paper as well
they say they want these things and
right actually they meet that person and
it's like we see that in shows where
they match people on on paper and then
they bring them on a date together and
sometimes they have no chemistry i think
it doesn't account for the fact that so
much of attraction we actually can't pin
down something is sometimes it's just
it's something that you can't um
like it's just it's just a random
something and you can't pin it down to
whether it's height or whatever i think
of course people have
base levels of it and again the same
thing of natural selection i think it's
just i think it's just more like
societal trends right that we're seeing
so like for example like women aren't
settling because the average age of
first marriage keeps going up and up and
up like you know what it is in the uk
no i don't it's 31 and 32. in ireland i
was just there it's 34 and 35. is it
that high now and they're predicting
that 50 percent of women will be single
and childless like 20. i think 50 of
women over 30 yeah will be single and
childless so it's all single children
so so it's like like the these patterns
aren't conducive for families because
it's not good for kids to not have both
parents in the home